oui ans michel butor vous êtes allé aux
états unis vous avez fait un long voyage
annoncé joue sept mois et puis une fois
rentré il fallait bien écrire un livre
et bien quand je suis parti pour les
etats-unis je savais qu'en rentrant en
france
j'aurais au moins à en parler et que
j'aurai certainement envie d'écrire
quelque chose dessus j'étais tout à fait
sûr d'avant ce que ce pays me fascine
ray et que ce pays me poserai des me
poserait des problèmes nouveaux
ça n'a pas manqué avoue écrivain oui
aussi
pendant tout mon séjour là bas je me
suis posé ce problème
comment parler des états unis comment
représenter les états unis vous vouliez
faire un livre
à l'image des états unis eh bien oui
j'ai voulu faire un livre à l'image des
états unis parce que lorsqu'un écrivain
va aux états unis habituellement il en
rapporte un livre c'est maintenant une
véritable tradition on va aux états unis
et puis on publie ensuite son journal de
voyage ou ses souvenirs de voyage et
j'ai trouvé en lisant certains de ces
livres que les anecdotes qui étaient
racontées par les écrivains qui était
forme juste et bien la façon dont on les
raconte et les rangs des fausses
parce que on ne comprenait pas dans quoi
elle était dans quel milieu
ces histoires se placer je dirais
presque dans quel monde
cela se passait est ce que j'ai cherché
à fait c'est a montré cet espace ce
milieux dans lesquels dans lequel les
choses arrivent et qui permet aux choses
par conséquent de prendre leur sens dans
le livre que j'ai publié il y as
extrêmement peu de souvenirs de voyage à
proprement parler ils forment des petits
détails dans un ensemble beaucoup plus
vaste
alors comment
vous essayez tente et réussit de rendre
cette énormité américaine eh bien je
voulais rendre cette immensité
sans faire un livre qui soit tout de
même trop énorme valait donc avec un
livre de dimension normale pour évier
devait être énorme
non non non non non non non justement je
ne voulais pas faire un livre énorme
mais je voulais donner le sentiment de
la dimension des états unis et c'est
pourquoi j'y joue en partie
j'ai choisi comme formes fondamentales
de ce texte non pas la phrase ou le
récit mais la nomenclature la liste
parce que une phrase c'est une structure
fermée lien points on ne peut rien y
ajouter tandis qu'une liste fera cela
marquise sortit à cinq par exemple une
liste une liste ça peut toujours être
quelque chose d'ouvert
on a toujours le sentiment qu on
pourrait rajouter encore un élément à
une telle liste liste communiste de
catalogue une liste comme une liste de
catalogue aux etats unis les les
catalogues joue un rôle absolument de de
premier plan
et lorsque j'étais aux états unis pour
apprendre les états unis pour essayer de
pour essayer de me familiariser avec la
vie quotidienne
eh bien j'avais une sorte de bréviaire
j'avais une sorte de dykes de
dictionnaires fondamentale qui étaient
les grands catalogues les gigantesque
catalogue que publie là bas les grands
magasins par correspondance chaque fois
que je voulais savoir le nom d'un objet
ménager par exemple et bien au lieu de
prendre un dictionnaire qui meurent est
souvent un dictionnaire habituel qui
meurent est souvent renseigner les
façons très imparfaite
je cherchais dans un de ces énormes
catalogue et c'est énorme catalogue ont
été ainsi le moyen paru un des moyens
principaux par lesquelles
j'ai appris les états unis un peu comme
on apprend une langue
d'ailleurs dans le livre il y à de
nombreuses citations de ses catalogues
il ya de nombreuses citations de deux
catalogues des deux plus grands magasins
par correspondance et séduit les les
extraits les citations de ces deux
catalogues se répondent forme un champ
si vous voulez à deux voix avec nous
regardions votre livre est comme
l'expliqué la la structure est bien le
livre est formé de deux couches
il y a des passages qui sont écrits en
caractères romains et d'autres qui sont
écrits en caractères italic ces deux
couches joue l'une avec l'autre
les caractères romains sont pourrait-on
dire
pour prendre l'exemple d'une partition
les caractères romains représente la
main gauche du piano représente une
espèce de basse fondamentales sur
lesquelles les caractères en italique
les passages en italique apporte des
illustrations apporte des mélodies si
vous voulez mais que disent le caractère
roman est bien n'est qu'une trame des
caractères les textes en caractères
romains et tendent sur l'ensemble des
etats-unis
une sorte de réseau et c'est à
l'intérieur des mailles de ce réseau que
les caractères en italique vont apporter
leur illustration
mais que signifie chaque mot imprimé en
caractères romains les points de repère
les mots imprimés en capital sont tous
des noms de villes un des aspects les
plus frappants pour moi des états unis
c'est l'homonymie c'est que aux états
unis le même mot désigne des quantités
de choses différentes salles est
particulièrement sensible pour les
villes et se fait là
a comme résultat que la relation entre
les mots et les choses n'est pas la même
aux etats unis qu'en europe vous voyez
là la différence de milieux mental que
cela implique
les villes ont très fréquemment le même
nom les villes ont fait des des petits
si vous voulez et les noms de villes ont
essaimé sur tout le territoire des
etats-unis pour réaliser cette trame
j'ai pris la suite des états dans
l'ordre dans lequel on la donne
habituellement là bas qui est l'ordre
alphabétique et j'ai cherché de chaque
état à l'état suivant quels étaient les
villes ou villages homonyme et bien pour
tous les états j'ai réussi à trouver un
assez grand nombre de mots nîmes ce qui
montre à quel point ces norcy même nom
sont répandues dans tout l'ensemble du
territoire
mais il y avait beaucoup trop de ses
homonymes pour faire pour permettre
d'apporter une véritable structure
l ouvrage c'est pourquoi j'ai ajoutés à
ce premier ordre un second ordre qui se
combine avec lui chacun de ces noms de
ville appelle la ville homonyme dans les
états voisins et ceux ci progressivement
on fait ainsi des trajets à partir d'un
état en allant au voisin puis au voisin
de celui là et cetera
on revient à l'état on part dans une
autre direction
chaque état est ainsi comme un foyer de
rayonnement et les états axe accroche
ainsi les uns les autres et puis je vous
demander pourquoi vous n'avez pas
indiqué
d'emplois au lecteur dans une préface
vous savez écrire les préfaces les
pressiers celle que vous avez fait
preuve de style rome autre jour et bien
je vous n'êtes pas la première personne
ce n'est pas la première fois qu'on me
pose cette question mais évidemment je
crois qu'il vaut mieux que ce soit les
autres qui écrivent des articles de
critique sur les ouvrages et un livre
comme celui là il présente un caractère
déroutant eh bien naturellement ce
caractère déroutant est voulu il se
présente telle qu'elle est
il doit pouvoir tenir sans trop
d'explication préalable
je veux quand je publie un livre je veux
t'il qu'il fasse son effet symbolique
qu'il apporte son coup tout seul et je
veux que le lecteur soit d'abord des
routes et désemparé je prends le risque
volontairement je prends le risque que
le lecteur se perdent
je veux qu'ils se perdent dans le livre
avant de s'y retrouver
un voyageur se perd aux états unis
éventuellement comme un voyageur se perd
dans n'importe quel pays
nouveau et lorsqu'il s'y retrouve
eh bien naturellement louvre âge où le
pays s'ils s'y retrouve s'il a eu à s'y
retrouver tout seul
l'ouvragé le pays lui fait un effet
beaucoup plus considérables que six ans
lui a par trop mâcher la besogne
c'est un guide pour se perdre d'abord et
pour se retrouver ensuite c'est cela